i called it mannequin madness because at
first i thought i might be a little
crazy doing this
i'm a woman with no experience in an
industry that no one's really heard of
everyone kind of looked at me a little
side eye what are you doing for a living
[Music]
my name is judy i'm the owner of
mannequin madness in oakland california
we sell new mannequins recycled
mannequins and we put together diy
projects involving the use of a
mannequin
[Music]
mannequin madness began as an accident
in 2000 the time i was working at a dot
com startup and everybody there was a
serial entrepreneur now at that point no
one looked like me who was an
entrepreneur i had never thought about
entrepreneurship but i thought this
could be maybe an interesting little
side hustle
i realized that department stores were
throwing away mannequins if they were
closing or remodeling i knew there was a
need for a secondary market for these
used mannequins but the stores didn't
want to deal with that so i started with
50 mannequins that i bought from the
seller on craigslist and six month
period of time i went to 500 mannequins
in my inventory so we went from renting
to selling we started using our photo
studio where people could come in to
rent to take pictures and then when
e-commerce came along i was able to
apply new technology strategies to an
old school business and that really
propelled me to a whole new level of
success
mannequins are made of materials that do
not biodegrade fiberglass plastic
styrofoam metal these things do not need
to be put in the landfill but prior to
us that was kind of generally what most
stores would do so we make it easy we
make it free for them i have a network
across the country so i can pretty much
recycle mannequins in most major cities
throughout the us
i say we average about 300 000 pounds of
mannequins every three months
i had no idea it had this kind of
potential but i've always been big about
how can we repurpose something and
create some more value out of it so
that's really what drove me and making
money came along with that we're going
to be on target this year to reach a
million dollars in sales for a small
business like us
that's a big target
it's called mannequin madness for a
reason because you don't know what
you're going to see when you get here
we have a warehouse showroom our
inventory changes depending on whatever
store we're working with so today we got
a truckload of mannequins from a
department store next week we may get
something from a smaller boutique
people use mannequins for all kinds of
art stuff you know i have mannequins in
the garden i've had mannequins that i've
turned into lamps i even have a little
mannequin that's shaped like a little
butler that has a little tray i like
that there's a little space here where
we really like you said being creative
and allowing other people to be creative
as well
i feel this is the greatest time in
history for an african-american woman to
start a business there has never been so
much emphasis on support giving people
visibility even though there's a lot of
challenges in the 20 years i've been in
business this has been the best time
ever
you really need to have technology for
your business at my age i'm starting to
learn how to be on tick tock
look at my family i've never seen a
whole family of such interesting looking
mannequins
here i'm a mid-life woman i'm in my 60s
i'm far away from the fashion capital
all these things that technically i
should not be a success in doing this
and i am and that really makes me
excited
[Music]
you